today's video is sponsored by short form
you don't have time to read every book
ever written and that's where short form comes in
you guys can get a five day trial to their
times saving book guides more on them in a bit
we talked a lot about the ancient empires that
were centered thousands of years ago in that
cradle of civilization known as mesopotamia
we've talked about the acadians the babylonians
the persians and today we're going to take a
look at the assyrians specifically we're going
to examine the life of ashubanapol arguably the
greatest king of assyria he held dominion over the
neo-assyrian empire which in his time was the most
far-reaching empire in history while its capital
nuneva was probably the largest richest and most
magnificent city in the ancient world ashabanapal
is best remembered for his royal library which
had amassed a gigantic collection unlike any
before it thanks to the king's zealous hoarding
of texts but make no mistake ashabanapol was a
ruthless and bloodthirsty warmonger one the
likes of whom the world had seldom seen up
to that point he transformed his mighty assyrian
army into a war machine that mercilessly stomped
his enemies into submission the egyptians
the babylonians the alamites the simerians
the arabs they all faced the wrath of ashabanapal
born circa 685 bc bashabana paul was the son of
esherhaden king of the neo-syrian empire and
one of his royal wives perhaps ashara hamad the
only one whose name we know ashabanapol was part
of the sargoni dynasty of assyria which ended
up being the empire's last dynasty before its
complete collapse but also represented assyria
at the height of its power between approximately
2000 bc and 500 bc mesopotamia was dominated by
two cultures the assyrians and the babylonians
who ostensibly took turns in being the regional
hegemon ashurbanipal's great-grandfather sargon
ii founded the sargani dynasty by usurping throne
from his predecessor in 722 bc and ushering in one
final golden age for assyria he was succeeded by
senate cherub in 705 bc who grew his empire's
power even further and unleashed utter destruction
on his kingdom's arch-enemy babylon leaving the
city in ruins following a brutal siege and sacking
however his biggest contribution was moving
his empire's capital to the city of nineveh
and undertaking massive construction projects to
transform it into the envy of the ancient world
after him came ashabanapal's father esha haddan in
681 bc even though he was sent a cherub's son he
distanced himself from his father both in texts
and in he considered that it would be better to
appease the babylonians rather than rule them
through fear and violence so one of his most
ambitious projects was to rebuild what sennacherib
had destroyed eshe haddon restored all of
babylon's important buildings and structures and
even took part in religious ceremonies honoring
the babylonian gods such as marduk that being said
echehaden wasn't completely peaceful and although
he showed a lot of favor to babylon that did
not extend to other vassal states such as saigon
and iratu which tried to rebel before being once
again dominated by the assyrian army eshehaden
also attacked new lands most notable of all being
egypt which he conquered in 671 bc the assyrian
drove out the reigning pharaoh and became the
first mesopotamian ruler to give himself the title
king of egypt esha haddan had a large family and
ashurbanipal was probably his fourth eldest son
nobody expected him to ascend to the throne which
is why he most likely trained as a scribe or a
priest when he was young however escher hadn't
had been a sickly man throughout his life and
so were many of his children his eldest son and
crown prince died unexpectedly around 672 bc
so esta haddon was left with a task of deciding
which offspring would become the new ruler he
decided that there should be two kings the king of
assyria and the king of babylon although the two
were technically equal everybody knew that
the king of assyria was the true ruler who
governed the whole empire for whatever reason
ershaden dismissed his third son as a candidate
scholars speculate that this was because the boy
was already in poor health so it was assumed that
he wouldn't live very long that left the king
with his second and fourth oldest sons shamash
again we don't know what reasoning esha
hadn't had but he named ashabanapal as his
true successor while the older brother was
given the lesser title of king of babylon
afterwards he had all of his vassals recognize
ashabanapol as his legitimate heir by issuing
a decree called the loyalty treaty of nakia
zakutu named after ashabanapal's grandmother
this came in handy because esha haddon did not
have a lot of time left even though the king was
already in poor health he marched to fight
the egyptians in 669 bc who were rebelling
against a syrian rule he died on the way but the
steps that he took previously ensured that the
transition of power went smoothly and each
son accepted his new role at least for now
in 668 bc ashabanapal became the ruler
of the neo-assyrian empire the largest
and most powerful empire that the world had ever
seen up to that point his priority was to finish
what his father had started and bring egypt back
under his dominion the conquest of egypt was not
an easy one eschaton's first attempt had been
repelled and even when he had been successful in
sacking thieves in 671 bc he was unable to capture
the pharaoh tahako or tahara who fled to kush
now tahako was back and with reinforcements and
after occupying memphis he forced all the local
officials to recognize him as pharaoh of egypt
again therefore in 667 bc ashurbanipal marched
on egypt to crush the rebellion once and for
all fortunately for us ashurbanipal was an
incredibly thorough record keeper archaeologists
have recovered numerous tablet cylinders reliefs
and other artifacts that were commissioned in
his time and detail his exploits all of his
successes at least he wasn't as diligent when
it came to preserving his failures for posterity
anyway one of these artifacts is known as the
rasam cylinder and it gives a long first-hand
account of most of his military campaigns so
we might as well find out how it happened from
the king of assyria himself he said in my first
campaign i marched against tahaka king of egypt
and ethiopia whom eshardon king of assyria the
father who begot me had defeated and whose land
he brought under his sway this same tahaka forgot
the might of ashur ishtar and the other great gods
my lords and put his trust upon his own power he
turned against the kings and regrets whom my own
father had appointed in egypt he entered and took
residence in memphis the city which my own father
had conquered and incorporated into a syrian
territory at these deeds my heart became enraged
my soul cried out i raised my hands in prayer to
assure and the assyrian ishtar i busted my mighty
forces which assured ishtar had placed in my hands
against egypt and ethiopia i directed the march
in the course of my march 22 kings of the seacoast
of the midst of the sea and of the mainland
servants subject to me brought their rich presence
before me and kissed by feet those kings together
with their forces on their ships by sea on the
dry land with my armies i caused to take path
and road tarko king of egypt and ethiopia heard of
the advance of my army in memphis and mustered his
fighting men against me offering armed resistance
in battle with the help of the great gods my lords
who advance at my side i defeated his army
in a battle on the open plain tahako heard of
the defeat of his armies while in memphis the
terrible splendor of asur and ishtar overcame
him and he went mad the glory of my majesty
with which the gods of heaven and earth have
crowned me overpowered him he forsook memphis
and fled to save his life to thebes that city
i seized i had my troops enter and occupy
it ashabanapal could be pretty cruel even
by ancient standards as evidenced by the fate of
the cities that plotted against him and the people
of sais pinetti snoo and the rest of the cities
as many as had joined wisdom in plotting evil
they struck down with the sword both great and
small not a man among them escaped their corpses
they hung on stakes they stripped off their
skins and covered the city walls with them as
for toharco he fled once again and died in 664 bc
ashabanapal then installed naco the first as the
new ruler under his vassalage and went home hoping
that that would be the end of it but it wasn't
the end because tahago had appointed a successor
named tantamani or tanwittamani and he also tried
to retake egypt prompting a second campaign from
the assyrians that very same year ashabanapal was
once again successful and this time his actions
were more drastic and definitive ending the sack
of thebes in 663 bc a momentous event that is
even mentioned several times in the bible he
effectively ended the nubian line of pharaohs and
returned to nineveh rich in plundering including
silver gold precious stones and all the wealth
of the palace rich cloth precious linen great
horses supervising men and women two obelisks
of splendid electrum weighing 2 500 talents
now we'll continue with today's story in just a
moment but first a word from a brand new sponsor
short form if you like my channels then you
probably like learning stuff a lot of you
guys like to expose yourself to new ideas or new
information by reading which is great but the last
two decades have seen an exponential rise in the
amount of content that's available for consumption
from youtube content like this very video you're
watching right now to articles podcasts and
of course traditional books if you're like me
you probably feel that there's never enough time
in the day to consume everything that you think
is interesting that's where short form comes in
they hijack the central themes and need to know
ideas from hundreds of books making them easily
available to you in consumable packages and this
can be really convenient too for instance you know
there's a massive 500 page tone that you've been
thinking about reading but you're not sure if it's
something you want to invest all of your free time
in pop into short form check out the summary and
you'll have a much better idea of whether or not
it's worth your time short form is also a great
tool for books you've already read listen to their
guides once a book is complete and it can give you
additional insight into some of the major motifs
or maybe you read something a long time ago and
you want a little refresher either way it won't
be long before you're walking around with the
confidence of an english lit major if you want a
recommendation today i'd recommend prisoners of
geography 10 maps that explain everything about
the world i don't want to spoil anything it's
an absolute must-read do go check it out on short
form right now you guys can get a free unlimited
short form trial for five days plus a discounted
annual subscription just go to shortform.com
forward slash biographics to check it out
there's a link below and back to today's video
despite his triumph in egypt ashurbanipal's
influence over the region began decreasing almost
immediately and this time the king did little
to stop this part of the reason why was because
egypt was at the outskirts of his empire so from
a logistical standpoint it was a lot of effort to
march his army there from nineveh another reason
was that ashubanapol had other revolts enemies
and projects to deal with so he did not want to
dedicate all of his time and energy towards egypt
inside of syria ashby nepal had a lot of ambitious
construction plans especially in the capital of
nineveh during his time some scholars believe that
nunavut became the largest city in the world with
a population of approximately a hundred and twenty
thousand people his grandfather senate chariot had
built a massive opulent palace in the capital
which became known as the palace without rival
due to its grandeur not to be outdone
ashabanapal constructed his own palace but
also new temples to the gods as well as city
walls and gates which were adorned with reliefs
that even to this day constitute some of the most
detailed and well-preserved examples of assyrian
art many of the reliefs show ashabanapol engaged
in lion hunting which was not only considered the
sport of kings but also a symbol of a ruler's
ability to protect his people from assyria's
enemies but the walls and the temples all paled in
comparison with the king's most ambitious project
the royal library of ashabanapol this may
have been the first great library in the
world older than the more famous library of
alexandria ashabanapol possessed a thirst for
knowledge almost like an obsession the
same way other kings would crave jewels
gold and other treasures all the cities in his
empire were ordered to bring him copies of the
most important texts and tributes and he sometimes
even conquered new settlements just to get his
hands on their libraries his reasoning was thus i
ashibanapol king of the universe on whom the gods
have bestowed intelligence i have placed these
tablets for the future in the library of nineveh
for my life and for the well-being of my soul
to sustain the foundations of my royal name
soon after ashabanapal's death the library was
destroyed in a fire but this turned out to be
a real boon for archaeology most of the text was
written on clay tablets and they didn't burn in
the fire they were actually hardened and then
got buried in the rubble they were rediscovered
during the mid 19th century and since then over
30 000 tablets and fragments have been recovered
becoming one of the greatest troves of information
about the ancient world construction projects and
scholarly pursuits aside ashabanapol was still a
warmonger at heart and he remained involved in one
military conflict or another for most of his reign
again going by the rat and cylinder after his two
campaigns in egypt ashabanapal fought some of the
other smaller kingdoms that either tried to rebel
or provided aid to his enemies this included tar
and award to phoenician states and the neo-hittite
kingdoms called tabal and hilaku he then sent aid
to king gaijis of lydia in his fight against the
sumerians and then invaded the land of the manians
however the biggest conflict at this time was his
war with the elamites elam was a civilization that
settled north of the persian gulf next to sumer
occupying the western part of modern-day iran it
remains to this day a preeminent yet mysterious
culture of the ancient world preeminent because it
was around for over 2 600 years mysterious because
almost everything we know about them comes from
second-hand sources like the acadian sumerians
babylonians egyptians and of course the assyrians
the alabite language seems to have developed in
isolation from its neighbors and has yet to be
fully deciphered one thing we do know is that
entered into direct conflict with assyria in the
late 8th century bc during the reign of sargon ii
he was ashubanappal's great-grandfather the two
sides continued to fight during the reigns of
senecarab and eshehaden but ashabanapal decided
that he would end the war once and for all by
annihilating the elamite civilization this was a
drawn-out affair that occurred over two different
campaigns but once again we can let ashubanapul
himself tell us what happened like a terrible
hurricane i overwhelmed alarm in its entirety
i cut off the head of tumen the king countless
of their warriors i slew with their corpses i
filled the plane about souza their blood i let
run down the ally it's water i died red like wool
although victorious ash banapal had to end his
first campaign against alam in a hurry because he
received word that alliance of medes simerians and
persians took advantage of his departure and
launched a surprise attack on nineveh therefore
bashabanapo returned to his capital and with the
help of his allies the scythians he managed to
repel the invaders in alarm he installed a new
king before leaving but it didn't take long for
the elamites to rebel against him therefore in
647 bc ashbanipal marched on alam again this time
he enacted widespread destruction including
raising the capital of susan to the ground
sousa the great holy city abode of their gods
seat of their mysteries i conquered i entered its
palace as i opened their treasuries where silver
and gold goods and wealth were amassed i destroyed
the ziggurat of susa i smashed its shining copper
horns i reduced the temples of elum to nought
their gods and goddesses i scattered to the wind
the tombs of their ancient and recent kings i
devastated i exposed to the sun and i carried
away their bones towards the land of ashore i
devastated the provinces of alarm and on their
lands i sowed salt anyone of royal alamite blood
was made a slave most of the population was
relocated and the cities and fields were left
empty ashabanapal thought that if he turned alarm
into a wasteland it would no longer be a threat
however because fate can have a cruel sense of
humor the exact opposite happened the persians
took over that territory and slowly began
rebuilding it while also gaining an important
foothold in the region just a few decades after
alarm's destruction assyria would fall as well
that's still in the future though for now
ashabanapal had another problem to contend
with one that many regarded as inevitable his
brother shammush to nobody's surprise he was never
happy that his father named his younger brother as
heir to his empire while he received the inferior
mostly ceremonial title king of babylon for 16
years he bided his time until he decided to strike
in 652 bc the civil war erupted although it
seems that shemashum okin's goal was to achieve
independence for babylon and become its true king
rather than an attempt to usurp the throne of the
whole empire according to some inscriptions he
had been plotting against his brother for years
and had conspired with alum against ash banapal
they weren't the only ones either as once the war
started shamash kin found plenty of other allies
willing to fight on its side to gain independence
for their kingdoms this included the arameans the
chaldeans and the kingdoms of gutien and muru even
so it seems like the strength of this coalition
was no match for assyria although as they say
history is written by the pictures and in this
case we only have ashurbanipal's inscriptions to
use as a source unsurprisingly he is presented as
being nigh indestructible thanks to the protection
of asur and ishtar i trod them underfoot to
their farthest border the yoke of a sewer which
they had cast off i placed upon them revenues
dues and first fruits for the gods of assyria i
imposed upon them my royal tribute and tax yearly
without ceasing i laid upon them it seems that
most rebellion kingdoms got off pretty easy
especially since ashbaner paul had a reputation
of being exceedingly cruel to his enemies however
that was not also the case for babylon the
assyrian king mounted a siege on the city that
lasted over two years driving the population
into starvation with one inscription mentioning
that the babylonians had to resort to cannibalism
by eating the flesh of their sons and daughters to
stay alive when the city finally fell in 648 b.c
mckinnon committed suicide by fire as for the
rest of the sinners as ashabadopoul called them
this was their fate as for those men and their
vulgar males who uttered vulgarity against assure
my god and plotted evil against me i slit their
mouths and brought them low the rest of the people
alive by the colossae between which had cut down
sena cherub the father of the father who begot me
at that time i cut down those people there as an
offering to his shade their dismembered bodies
i fed to the dogs swine wolves and eagles to
the birds of heaven and the fish of the deep
ashabanapal's final military campaign that we know
of took place in the arabian peninsula against the
various kingdoms that were situated there he first
took up the sword against a king named uwait who
is known only from this inscription he was a
former vassal who allied himself with shamish
shimokin during the failed rebellion according
to the rasam cylinder ash banapal defeated ouit
in battle but he did not kill him as he had a more
humiliating punishment in mind for him instead he
placed the former king in a kennel alongside dogs
and jackals so he would guard one of the gates
into nineveh afterwards ashabanapal fought amaladi
king of the kuderites after the latter invaded a
kingdom that was under assyrian protection again
ash banipal was triumphant and he stuck his enemy
in a dog kennel his final foes were two brothers
imu and rba who were the sons of a king who also
rebelled alongside the babylonians they too were
defeated and taken prisoner and it seems that abia
died of thirst on his way to nineveh while
amu was flayed alive in the assyrian capital
ashbanipal also conquered the cities of ushu
and akka massacring its people and capturing its
treasures for refusing to pay tribute to him now
we arrive at the mysterious end of his reign which
is full of guesswork and debatable ideas due to a
lack of sources sometime around 630 bc ashabanapal
fell ill and traveled to the city of haran in
modern-day turkey at that point he disappears from
the historical record so he was either deposed or
most likely he died there of some unknown illness
his son asha atollani became the new king of the
neo-assyrian empire but he lacked the strong will
ruthlessness and determination of his father
and all of assyria's vassals knew this and many
revolts occurred in the years that followed the
syrians the medes the babylonians emerged as the
greatest threat to assyria as they banded together
to bring down the once mighty war machine that had
subjugated them all the external strife might also
have been compounded by a civil war between asha
attiliani and his brother sin shah ishkun who
may have wanted the assyrian throne for himself
we know that the first sibling only ruled for
a few years before being succeeded by sinsha
ishkan but we have no idea if asha ettalani died
or was usurped his brother had a longer reign of
approximately 15 years but it mainly consisted
of sinsha ishkan desperately trying to hold on
to his crumbling empire ultimately he failed
and the once mighty capital of nineveh fell
in 612 bc thus marking the end of the neo-assyrian
empire and the start of the neo-babylonian empire
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget to
subscribe and as always thank you for watching